de format nous avons suivi l'ordre du
jour qui concernait les différents
aspects des accords portant sur le
règlement de la situation dans de basses
avec l'activation des groupes de
contacts et sur différentes orientations
bien précise n'est aulas à la résolution
des questions humanitaires et diraient
les différents aspects de règlement de
la situation sur le terrain en accord
avec les accords de mise de 2015 nous
avons constaté que sur les neuf points
du document final du format non mendier
seulement un point a été respectée c'est
en l'occurrence les échanges de
prisonniers
deux échanges ont été effectués
notamment 230 personnes ont été échangés
entre kiev d'une part et donetsk est
lougansk que récemment encore et nous
nous sommes prononcés pour la poursuite
de ces échanges de prisonniers et sur la
base de tous contre tous ce qui
correspond à l'ensemble des mesures qui
avaient été prises
la question de l'amnistié n'a toujours
pas été résolu et pour l'instant il n'a
pas été possible de modifier les teneur
de l'accord en ce qui concerne les
autres points sur lesquels il était le
chi dont il était question aujourd'hui
notamment l'attribution d'un statut
particulier aux deux basses tout cela
c'est l'objet est la base de ce
règlement et nous sommes convaincus que
nous pourrons avancer sur ce plan est
dedans donné un premier aspect
positif mais malheureusement on ne peut
se féliciter de rien puisque kiev n'a
toujours pas établi de discours direct
de discussions directes avec les
républiques autoproclamées et donc tous
les as les autres aspects liés à cet
accord et à l'exécution de de ces
accords ne peut être résolu pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'aspect concret
pour l'instant qui ont été proposés ni
selon la formule jeu terne mayer qui
donc proposer des aspects concrets de
discussions notamment en matière
d'attribution de statut spécial autant
de base et par conséquent nous avons une
fois de plus appelé d'autres collègues à
exercer une pression sur les autres
participants de la discussion n'est pour
donner un an peut-être que l'ordre n'est
pas le meilleur terme ici mais en tout
cas nous appelons encore une fois à la
complète cessation des hostilités et là
encore malheureusement nous n'avons pas
de résultats tangibles ici pour
l'instant et le sèche-cheveux de juillet
2009 qui avait dessiné n'a toujours pas
été respectées nous avons mené des
statistiques cobras ont montré des
statistiques effectuées par l'ol sur
place ce n'est sa mission sur place
les bombardements de localités se
poursuivre et l'eau qu'elle était située
sur le territoire qui est sous contrôle
des autorités de donetsk et de l'audace
or il n'y a eu aucune
aucun autre bombardement dans l'autre
sens
ce sont les statistiques de loisirs
aujourd'hui nous avons appelé kiev
donath donetsk est lougansk à à prendre
des mesures supplémentaires pour que le
respect du cessez le feu soit assurée et
qui correspond à la mission de
surveillance qui avait été mise en place
il ya un certain temps par l'ouest avec
la publication des ordres qui sont
données en la matière interdiction des
opérations de sabotage de diversion et
l'interdiction de bombardé des sites
civils
tout le monde était d'accord là dessus
or pour l'instant kiev a refusé de
signer cet accord proposé par l'ouest
nous avons parlé encore une fois de
l'importance d'assister sur le le
caractère intangible désaccord et je
vous rappelle que le sommet de paris qui
réunissait les chefs d'état et les chefs
des diplomaties des pays concernés et
les dirigeants du format normandie
s'étaient mis d'accord pour un retrait
efforts sur l'ensemble de la ligne et le
président ukrainien a catégoriquement
refusé de suivre cette voie
probablement pour dépression est liée à
la politique intérieure
il avait insisté que pour que trois
points de séparation des forces soit
identifiée sur cette ligne de contact
mais pourrait pour ajouter ce point haut
à l'accord de paris mais aujourd'hui on
voit que les bonnes volontés de des
républiques
je me heurte à un refus systématique de
la part de kiev
je le répète encore une fois c'est
regrettable que à paris il n'y ait pas
eu cet appel à la séparation des phares
sur la totalité de la ligne de contact
on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya d'autres la
situation et lou de différentes et nous
espérons que encore une fois que de kiev
retirera prochainement le flotus que
qu'il exerce sur les républiques de john
bass et il ya un certain nombre de
problèmes humanitaires qui doivent être
résolus nous avons sensibilisé nos
collègues français là dessus et le
groupe de contact pour que le travail
soit effectué de façon plus active
donc cette voie et en ce qui concerne le
d'une basse nous avons encore une fois
sur v la question des de la situation
humanitaire sur plus au terrain nous
avons également attiré l'attention sur à
propos des préoccupations humanitaires
qui concerne en priorité le taux de base
puisque c'est l'objet majeur de
discussions mais ça concerne aussi les
autres jean situé sur le le territoire
de l'ukraine suite mais nous avons
encore parlé aussi du projet de loi qui
avait été soumis à la rada à kiev qui
limite l'utilisation 2t langue
maternelle des langues minoritaires pour
les minorités nationales dans le pays
ceci sap notamment l'exécution des
dispositions des accords 2007 2015
dans certaines régions cela concerne
notamment certaines régions de donner
certains certaines localités de la
région de donetsk est lougansk douce
encore une fois nous insistons sur la
nécessité que l'eau c'est eux et heidi
grau notamment citoyenne suisse agisse
sur le terrain et nous avons fait un
appel
le groupe de contact à l'eau à eux pour
que le lot et se remplissent c'est sa
mission de façon objective et de façon
impartiale en faveur du règlement du
conflit ukrainien une nouvelle fois nous
avons encore dû insister sur le strict
respect des dispositions des accords de
minsk dans le détail et dans leur
ensemble
encore une fois par la voie du dialogue
direct entre kiev et donetsk est
lougansk que les discussions
d'aujourd'hui auront été positive et or
ont permis d'avancer un peu notamment au
niveau des groupes de contacts
peut-être avez-vous des questions chaîne
euronews monsieur la pop maintenant un
pan dans la quarantaine
comment évaluez vous la possibilité des
changements dans le cadre des
négociations du format normandie et que
la situation peut évoluer pour mettre
fin à ce conflit dans le deux balles
merci vous savez je pense que si on
prend en considération
l'affluence du coronavirus sûr
la politique je pense qu'il faut voir
l'affluence dans l'ensemble du monde de
cette vente est mis sur les différentes
crises sur les différentes situations
difficiles qui se présentent dans le
monde aujourd'hui nous avons bien
évidemment parler aussi du fait que
cette épidémie classe une certaine
influence sur les décisions et que c'est
une menace pour les habitants de ces
régions pour l'ensemble de l'état
ukrainien
encore une fois pour la présence
internationale qui est sur place et
notamment la mission sur place et
d'autres structures internationales
tout cela est évidemment être une source
de préoccupation cette pandémie se
manifeste sur toutes les entités que
j'ai cités mais nous avons aussi parlé
du fait que à l'égard des républiques de
données et de logo le rapport de l'ouest
convient certainement de critiquer nous
demandons d'influencé sur cette
situation dans la mesure où les
républiques de donetsk est lougansk
respectent des règles qui sont
suffisamment simple ce sont des règles
de franchissement des frontières
il s'agit simplement que les gens
puissent montrer qu'ils sont en bonne
santé et que les gens respectent la
quarantaine si nécessaire et donc dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions les
représentants de loi ce surplace ne
respecte ses règles
ce sont les mêmes règles que celles qui
a édicté
kiev pour le reste du territoire de le
cren ces règles ou ce sont plus douces
que celles qui ont édicté certains pays
européens
de plus je jouais seul la plupart de ses
présences sur place sur le terrain que
ce soit au kosovo au sonar grande et
vous ici de est présente sur place et a
gelé toutes ses opérations sur place et
pourquoi dans le casse dans le cas de
john bass line les dirigeants
d'admission et s'il ya des problèmes
c'est parce que c'est une politisation
de la situation qui est tout à fait
inacceptable et je me suis même
intéressé auprès de mes collègues pour
savoir si justement en allemagne par
exemple est ce que il ya des
instructions particulières pour la
mission de l'osce sur le terrain qu'est
ce qui permet de prendre des décisions
pareilles et si c'est le cas à ce moment
là il va falloir régler cette question
de l'accès de la bce sur les territoires
de donetsk et de lougansk pour
simplifier la question du règlement
donc pour répondre à votre question je
dirais simplement qu'il faut pas
attendre quelques cataclysme à l'échelle
mondiale pour forcer les gens se mettent
d'accord mais simplement respecter
consciencieusement les accords 2006 tels
qu'ils ont été conclus mais encore une
fois le problème principal je le dis
aujourd'hui c'est le l'absence de
réponse du clair de la part de kiev et
de réponse honnête consciencieuse
pour que ce dialogue s'établissent et
j'ai interrogé mes homologues français
et allemand
là dessus je leur ai demandé est ce que
berlin et paris sont prêts à insister de
leur poids sur le respect des accords de
minsk ce qu'ils peuvent exercer des
pressions sur kiev lé que kiev cesse de
refuser le dialogue direct avec les
républiques de donetsk est lougansk
agences non sur la grave des romans valu
que l'agent sign and not allowed
quelle réunion au niveau des ministres
des affaires étrangères des pays membres
du forum normandie tu demi après tu ne
bouges qui a duré plusieurs mois est
empressé de réunion importante le
président russe vladimir poutine a dit
que les pays importants pays qui
soutiennent les deux expressions occupe
tarifs qu'ils envoient leurs chars dans
le donbass
est-ce que vous avez évoqué ce sujet
aujourd'hui lors de la réunion entre les
ministres des affaires étrangères et une
autre question concernant la sécurité à
vous dit toujours que lé dakor de minsk
prévoit l'accès de leurs excès à toutes
les régions du donbass mais pourquoi on
utilise de la tendinite pour bloquer cet
accès map se souvient compagne convaincu
que vous avez entendu la réponse que je
donnais la réponse précédente
jeudi qu' aucune décision aucun blocage
pour la mission de l'asean existe de
bonnes bases
il ya simplement une politisation de
l'organisation de l'organisation autour
de cette question
encore une fois les règles de l'ouest
pour toutes ces missions sont les mêmes
et les pays qui ont de déléguer leurs
citoyens au sein de la mission devrait
se confirme qu'il n'y a aucune réduction
des compétences de l'eau et ce qui est
d'ailleurs la mission de rêve consiste
continuent d'avoir accès au territoire
comme partout dans le monde
quelle que soit la partie des
territoires des républiques de donetsk
est lougansk en accord avec la les
dirigeants les autorités de ces
républiques
si vous avez en vue la partie de la
frontière entre la russie et le crem
oui c'est vrai ils viennent
régulièrement là mais cela correspond
parfaitement au mandat que cette mission
spéciale de surveillance a reçu il ya
une résolution du conseil de sécurité
qui valait de tout cela tous ces
documents sont très claires et
d'ailleurs ils sont respectés en ce qui
concerne les chars et l'artillerie
nous l'avons dit nous le disons depuis
longtemps
quel que soit le confit il ya toujours
des conflits il ya toujours des trafics
d'armes qui accompagnent ces conflits et
qui envoie les armes et qui vous dit que
la russie fournit des armes est
accessible partout dans le monde et que
ce soit de kalachnikovs des systèmes
d'artillerie qui sont produis aussi
notamment dans certains pays d'europe
orientale et
cet armement circule partout dans le
monde relativement facilement bien
l'agent ou veronica ne vous avons pas
monsieur
la preuve est que c'est possible de
tenir on the change de prisonniers entre
1 qu'il ya peu de neige ce qu un parce
que cette situation est compliquée par
l'absence de l'accès à un prisonnier
dans ces régions vous savez l'accès aux
patients par le biais de j'en ai parlé
de ces jours ci avec le président de ce
comité
nous avons parlé de cet aspect n'est il
comprend très bien que pour avoir un
accès il faut s'entendre directement
avec les autorités concernées et nous
appelons au fait que intéressés se fasse
en direct encore une fois la question de
l'accès doit être résolu en direct s'il
y a un nouvel échange de prisonniers
donc il va y avoir une procédure qui va
ce qui doit se mettre en place
je vous rappelle que les accords des
mines stipule un accord tous contre tous
quand on échange des prisonniers et on a
parfois des la nécessité de préciser si
certains prisonniers veulent vraiment
aller de l'autre côté
donc c'est une procédure que je dirais
que à cette technique qui bien sûr n'est
pas dénué d'une certaine politisation
mais nous espérons que l'aspect
strictement humanitaire de cette
question au sein du groupe de travail
connaîtra certains résultats et là il ya
quand même un espoir
harper il ya peut-être un conte à vous
la parole
bonjour vous maintenant des biens mais
cela voix bonjour j'ai une question sur
un autre sujet que vous avez évoqué hier
lors d'une autre réunion sur le scandale
après la publication des journalistes
cheikh jeu sur un attentat contre les
hommes politiques tchèques
après leur diffusion à de détruire le
monument au marshall connaît est-ce que
c'est une coïncidence selon bout que ce
scandale a eu lieu à l'asie de la fête
de la victoire
qu'est ce que vous vous attendiez
intense que la réaction est marié à
dakar on voit vite qu'il y aura des
conséquences et d'encadrer des relations
entre moscou et prague et qu'elles
feront que compliquer instructions vous
connaissez bien évidemment toute la
chronologie de ces événements je ne veux
pas affirmer que le démontage du
monument de koné fini cumulé au public
correspond exactement à l'anniversaire
de la victoire sur le nazisme mais la
personne qui dirige la petite celle ci
qualité
nous avons déjà donné des commentaires
sur cette personne et je serai
pleinement respectée je me répéter je
veux pas attiré plus l'attention là
dessus mais simplement il faut je les
médias ont ce qu'il faut on les
informations prises faut donc il faut
donner une appréciation objective à ce
dieu et à ce qui paraît dans la presse
mme jacquet d'autres b si cette question
devient le premier ministre venu des
stingers qu'un autre état sur notre
territoire une action de foudre nos
citoyens mais ces problèmes inès qui le
dit alors si c'est vrai ou pas vrai
talent pourquoi dire pourquoi tenir des
propos pareils la question qui se pose
c'est s'il sont certains que certaines
personnes opérées sur leur territoire
alors ils disent les personnes ceux de
l'ambassade
plus personne du personnel de
l'ambassade n'est venu pour füle
alors si ni se retrouver dans toulouse
les affaires le coup de pouce ou le
passager dont je les documents pareil
comment vous elle peut comment vous
l'avez laissé passer sur votre
territoire
tout cela ce mois il ne paraît insensé
que légumes et quant aux collègues de
radio soit bodas la chine ou je me bats
un moule que tous arrêté de nouveau
grâce à ce coup sûr ce que détaillé
lier mon corps n'avait alors cette arme
qui était consacrée à l'homme qui
s'éteignait ce que laissait croire de
telles sornettes été jusqu'à ce génie
politique offrir cette fois ci c'est le
prince du tennis à 69,00 ce taux
d'audiences publiques et donc chaque
pays a ses lois 10-11 liberté parle donc
chacun peut déclarer ce qu'ils veulent
comme en touche tout donné il ya une
question de respect l'un envers l'autre
de souveraineté ingérence dans les
autres pays
tout cela figure dans l'accord signé par
la russie et la république tchèque en
cet accord stipule que les tchèques sont
tenues sous 2 prendre soin tous des
monuments et notamment du monument du
maréchal rosneft est de permettre
l'accès est associe la partie de
confirmer que cet accord c'est surtout
cette fois continue à être effective
donc nous attendons nous de notre part
nous attendons qu'il nous donne une
réponse et ouvre un dialogue complet sur
cette question pour savoir pourquoi ce
fonds a été simplement france donc nous
avons fait une proposition nous
attendons la réponse de la partie
tchèque facebook signé 10 milliards
l'agente le spoutnik et mia emiliano va
où là
entendez génial je ne comprends pas mais
que la drogue
donc merci merci nous attend pas
elle a manqué tout ce qui pour vous le
rencontrez selon lui à ce qu'on a dit
merci à vous